this video is sponsored by Factor happy
2024 you know what I'm going to be doing
this year getting in better shape you
know where that starts the kitchen and
if you haven't heard of factor yet then
boy oh boy are you in the right place no
matter how you eat currently or how you
would like to maybe start eating be that
keto vegan low calorie more meat more
Seafood more veggies Less meat however
Factor makes your dietary Choice simpler
than ever by delivering a custom number
of meals of your choice between 4 and 18
to your door every week fresh never
Frozen and quite frankly delicious for
my current goals I'm sort of doing a
high protein low calorie mix I have no
idea I'm eating really healthfully right
now and that's the greatest thing for
people like me and let me tell you
there's nothing quite as easy or
satisfying as popping a fresh Factor
meal in the microwave for 2 minutes and
enjoying a hot delicious meal and I
don't have to shop at the grocery store
which is a big plus if you want to be
like me and confidently upgrade your
nutrition with the easiest meals ever
head to factor75.com or click the link
below and use code Bandit games 50 to
get 50% off your first Factor box and
free wellness shots for Life two free
wellness shots from the three available
flavors for every order while you are an
active subscriber once again head to
factor75.com or click the link below and
use the code Bandit games 50 for 50% off
your first Factor box and free wellness
shots for life and now on to the
video lethal company a game that puts
you in the point of view of a
run-of-the-mill workingclass individual
a nameless employee a mere number in the
great Evert turning Cog of the
mysterious yet all knowing company wait
are we sure we're not just talking about
Real Life the game has been all over
social media for a few months now but in
case you still haven't heard of it it's
a multiplayer horror game that requires
players to work together in order to
survive visiting mysterious abandoned
facilities on desolate moons searching
for scrap and other kinds of junk to
meet a quota all the while dodging Death
Around Every Corner in the form of
monsters Falls or even just being left
behind by your ship because the
autopilot gave up on you like my first
prom date but in addition to all of this
the game also has an alarming amount of
incredibly interesting lore that's
sprawled out right under most players
noses and take it from me it goes way
deeper than you might think so in my
first video covering the story behind
the story of lethal company we're going
to dig deep and take a big bite out of
the company itself and by that I mean
the real company the Beast inside the
wall his name is Jeb and I think I
figured out exactly what Jeb is all
about now in case you haven't already
discovered it for yourself or seen some
of the other lore videos that have been
circulating on the platform I'm going to
go over all of the required information
in order to fully understand what we'll
be talking about in the video starting
with the setting for the entire in-game
universe lethal company takes place in
our solar system according to the
in-game logs which we know is ours
because well there may be many Star
systems out there but there's only one
solar system in the entire universe
named after our Sun's Latin name
Soul however the events of the game are
set with an a fictional nebula known as
the thistle nebula which was first
explored by humans aboard the space
vessel known only as the boat at some
point in time the thistle nebula is
composed of at least two planets the gas
giant known as big grin feels like
there's a joke somewhere and an unnamed
white dwarf star there are also at least
nine explorable moons within the nebula
three of which orbit big grin known as
41 experimentation its twin 220
assurance and another literally
splintered off of 220 Insurance called
21 offense the white dwarf star also has
three moons orbiting it known as 85 Ren
seven Dy and8 Titan there are also three
moons that have an unknown orbit within
the NEPA known as 56 V 61 March and 71
gordian which is the moon where the
company resides the planets cannot as of
yet be explored in game leaving The
Players to use the company provided ship
to travel to the different moons instead
always on a pre-programmed autopilot
what the moons all have in common is
that they all feature man-made
facilities and they're all completely
abandoned and devoid of any remaining
human life and one moon in particular 56
V was said to actually have been
inhabited by several colonies across
several continents these moons are
traveled to and from by employees of the
company in order to find pieces of scrap
to sell to the company at the company
Building located on 71 gordion which
they are given a deadline of 3 days to
accomplish but every time a quota of
scrap is met the next quota raises
meaning each multi-day scrap run is
increasingly more difficult employees of
the company face many difficulties
scouring the moons for Junk but in
addition to these difficulties there are
also two ways that the company itself
can pose a threat to their livelihood
the first of which would be to annoy Jeb
who lives inside the company building by
repeatedly pressing the service Bell
before Jeb Is Able by repeatedly
pressing the service Bell before Jeb is
ready to accept the offer of junk and
the second would be to fail to meet the
quota at this point employees are fired
from both their positions and from life
now scouring the moons of a fictional
nebula to appease a mysterious tentacle
monster hidden within a Mysterious Giant
building is all well and good but it
starts to get weirder when you take
notice of the time frame that the game
takes place in which has been adjusted a
little bit since the game has been
available to the public see prior to the
recent patch update version 47
the year in the game was at least $24.97
according to the bunker spider log entry
but after version 47 went live the log
entry detail was changed to 1965 and
this change alone removed all sorts of
assumptions that came along with the
game being futuristic and now leaves the
exact date of gameplay up to speculation
speaking of log entries though many of
them were written later in the 1960s by
a particular team of employees whose
names were Jess Richard who later got
replaced by Lucas and two brothers
Desmond and sigard the last of which is
the individual responsible for
single-handedly writing most of the logs
that we can find and read today and even
though spelling wasn't exactly sigur
strong suit vigorous note taking
absolutely was including the dates of
his personal logs the first of which was
written in 1968 this means that the
technology of the lethal company
Universe was far more advanced than our
own sigur refers to the terminal located
inside the ship as being old in 1968 and
granted this could make sense since
there were also computer terminals
around since the 50s in real life albeit
they were very rare but in addition to
this the company has been hosting this
Intergalactic space travel employment
for several years prior to the logs
being written yet we still don't do that
and it's 2024 regardless most of the
information for the games Universe can
be derived from these logs written by
sigur who apparently left a sticky note
behind for future employees which would
be us giving us a hint at how to unlock
the encrypted entry logs and this is
where things take a darker return see
there is no known actual human contact
in the company as sigard points out and
as we can even hear for ourselves every
Audible Voice heard sounds like
artificial intelligence sigard even
calls it a fake voice and as other lore
videos point out even the music played
in the company briefing message and from
the store delivery pod sounds off
somehow and not like Taylor Swift off
off like it was made by a program
algorithmically not creatively and also
I just wanted to mention before we move
on too far that apparently Accord into
this poster here humanity is in a famine
which has been in existence for who
knows how long at this point it's
currently unclear as to how this may or
may not relate to the company since the
company does not appear to have any
human contacts within but it's still
very interesting to point out
nonetheless but anyway back to the
company sigur records in a later log
that his brother Desmond was able to
trace the call that sigard placed to the
company requesting a new fourth member
after the death of Richard who died of
excessive stinkiness this traced call
came back with a location that was
nowhere near the company building on 71
Gordon according to Desmond whoever or
whatever picked up the phone on the
other side was located all the way
across the solar system this begs
several questions the first of which
obviously is well who's on the other end
of the phone when you call the company
but the next of which is if the company
voices aren't actually inside the
company building then who or what is
inside the company building well like I
said earlier it's a monster named Jeb
C's logs from August detail Audible
screams heard from behind its concrete
wall that he was able to hear using a
walkie-talkie although I wasn't able to
replicate this ingame sadly one day
sigard was able to actually talk to the
voice of a man allegedly coming from
inside the building and what this man
had to say was perhaps the most
interesting piece of lore that the game
has yet to offer he said that the
legendary golden planet was actually
real now the golden planet is apparently
an in Universe myth that some people say
was wiped out due to a meteor hitting it
but also that nobody actually believes
was real in the first place kind of like
the legend behind Santa Claus living at
the North Pole even though nobody
believes he's actually um maybe I
shouldn't say the man then claimed that
the planet was actually swallowed up by
something called the beast and that
quote they were in its body being
digested when sigur asked what the Beast
was the man said he didn't know but that
whatever it was ate the entire planet
and quote they forgot everything sigard
then told the man that he was inside of
the building and that the team could get
him out and this is when the man for an
unknown reason began freaking out and
screaming saying something about
spitting out the Rind sigard seemingly
shrugs off this entire encounter but if
you venture to the other side of one of
the storage units on 71 Gordon you can
open up a hatch and descend down a
ladder to some walkways underneath the
landing pad down here you can actually
find what appears to be a giant drill of
some sort that's currently unpowered
from its positioning and surroundings
and even words spray painted on its
sides we can deduce several things like
that it was purposefully placed here to
be secretive from the eyes of the
company that its platform is weighed
down in case of a water level rise and
that the wall in front of the drill is
the planned entry point which also just
so happens to be the wall behind which
Jeb is enclosed now gameplay wise most
fans speculate that this is going to be
an endgame feature to come in a future
update which will likely entail plugging
in at least two apparatuses for a power
source installing an unknown item for a
switch or lever and repairing the data
cable between the switch boox and the
drill body in order to activate the
entire mechanism and presumably breach
the wall but that's not the point right
now the point is lore and the lore
behind all of this I think is the rescue
mission that sigard talked about in his
log when he met the man beyond the wall
it's currently unknown as to why sigur's
crew wasn't able to finish this Rescue
Mission or where they even got all the
pieces from but I think a safe
assumption might be that they eventually
couldn't keep up with Jeb's ever growing
appetite quota and eventually were fired
now truth TR be told this is where the
game's lore stops abruptly we still
don't know where Jeb came from for
certain we still don't know what the
facility's purposes were originally or
why they've all been abandoned and we
still don't know where all those other
monsters came from that haunt the
hallways of the facilities to this day
but given what we do know which is that
the company building is really just a
holding facility for a giant formless
tentacle monster known as Jeb who
demands to be offered more and more
scrap by the day and who also may or may
not have multiple people digesting
inside him I think we can use some real
world lore to figure out at least one
piece of the giant puzzle and it all
stems from the name of the Moon that the
company building is located on its name
is 71 gordian astute historians might
remember that name off the bat but for
the rest of us who don't allow me to
Enlighten you gordion is the name of the
capital of ancient friia and its most
notable King was a man named Midas you
know as in the Midas touch as in
everything King Midas touches turns to
gold golden King Midas yeah the company
monster that consumes anything offered
to it is on a moon named after the
golden King Midas and the legend of the
golden Planet dictates that it was eaten
by the Beast the man beyond the wall
also claims that he and quote they are
inside the Beast and he's inside Jeb so
here's the hypothesis what if Jeb is the
Beast that ate the golden planet and the
golden planet is what we're standing on
71 gordion or at least what's left of it
anyway think about it it's listed in the
Moon's catalog but orbits no known
planet it also has no land masses
anywhere and no signs of life even
aquatic ones which could mean that it
was all consumed by the Beast maybe this
body of water is all that's left behind
and its significantly reduced mass now
classifies it as a Moon instead of a
planet and also maybe that body of water
isn't really water at all maybe that's
just more of the formless body of Jeb
furthermore it makes perfect sense that
the man beyond the wall who claimed that
the Beast made the people its consuming
forget about the golden Planet would
freak out after sigard reminded him that
he was inside the Beast being digested
at that very moment now like I mentioned
a bit ago we still don't know where
exactly this Beast came from but one
popular thesis is that it came to the
golden Planet as a meteor from outer
space like the man mentioned this would
mean that Jeb could literally be a deep
space lovecraftian life consuming
mind-altering tentacle monster that
travels through the cosmos consuming
planets it comes into contact with along
with any life forms present another
thesis that's based off of pure
speculation is that Jeb is the result of
nuclear warfare the literal physical
formless allc consuming manifestation of
War if you will but as of the present
neither of these have been confirmed
unfortunately there are still many
unknown questions in the game such as
who built the building around the Beast
and are the Beast and the company truly
one and the same but I digress what do
you think though do you think the golden
planet is what 71 Gordon used to be or
is it something else entirely and what
theories do you have about the game let
me know in the comments below I'm
especially interested in hearing your
thoughts on the various monsters in the
game since I'd love to cover them in a
future video thank you so much for
watching and if you'd be so kind please
consider leaving a like on the video If
you enjoyed it to get it spread around a
bit more on YouTube this is my first
time on the channel covering an indie
game so it's definitely kind of
nerve-wracking to say the least also
subscribe if you haven't already for
much more gaming lore to come huge
thanks as always to my Bandit crew of
which dragon xsx has recently joined up
that's all I've got in this one so be
sure to follow me on my socials and I'll
see you next time fellow employees this
is Bandit signing out
[Music]
peace